it's been about two months since we
first got our hands on the ipad air 4.
and in our initial review we were pretty
happy with it because of the excellent
performance
for things like gaming as well as the
new design that looks great
and supports the incredible magic
keyboard case
making it a perfect laptop replacement
however a lot has changed in the past
two months specifically the release of
apple's m1
macbook air which has been blowing
everyone's mind
because the base model for 999 dollars
has barely any drawbacks compared to the
more expensive
1300 macbook pro so in this review
i'm going to look at the ipad air 4 from
a different perspective
now considering the m1 macbook air
because it could actually be
a much better buy for a lot of people
but before i get into that i want to
talk about our experience
with the ipad air after 2 months the new
modern and sleek design has been giving
us an
excellent experience compared to apple's
previous budget 10.2 inch ipad
and ipad mini the new rounded corner
display is just so much more immersive
compared to those other ipads and this
feature alone
along with the premium flat design makes
it worth the extra cash
over those ipads seriously the design
makes all of the difference in
day-to-day use however i'm starting to
absolutely hate the new touch id sensor
because i'm used to using the ipad pro
with face id
which honestly works so much better than
touch id but in terms of performance
the a14 bionic chip in the ipad air is
really impressive
because i haven't noticed it being any
slower than the pro
for everything including gaming
performance
the only downside compared to the ipad
pro is that it doesn't get
the 120hz display but surprisingly
even without that the apple pencil
note-taking performance was
really great so overall i've been
extremely happy with the ipad air 4
over the past 2 months at least in terms
of
tablet use with it being very reliable
for both apps and games but perhaps my
favorite part about this new ipad air
is that it supports the magic keyboard
case which i absolutely love
because apple totally nailed the
keyboard
making it feel like an actual macbook
keyboard and as for the trackpad it also
feels like a macbook trackpad
because you get an even clicking feel no
matter where
you tap or click unlike windows laptops
which use a traditional diving board
design that doesn't feel great at all
and to my surprise it supports all of
the same gestures
like pinch to zoom and using three
fingers to swipe between apps
these gestures come directly from
macbooks
and they work incredibly well on the
ipad air with the magic keyboard case
and that's why i called it an excellent
laptop replacement the main downside is
that it costs three hundred dollars
and if you buy an apple pencil on sale
on amazon for a hundred dollars
to take advantage of the best
note-taking experience you can get on
any tablet
the price of this ipad air laptop setup
goes up to
exactly 1 000 making it the perfect
base macbook air contender now yes not
everyone wants a keyboard case for their
ipad
and even those who do can find other
options like the logitech folio touch
for a hundred and sixty dollars
but the magic keyboard case is the only
one that is
so good that it can actually compete
with the keyboard and trackpad
on a macbook air and that's why i chose
it
so now i'm going to get into the
advantages and disadvantages of buying
the ipad air 4
compared to buying the m1 macbook air
including things like day-to-day
experience professional
use app support performance gaming and
more
getting started the ipad air has the
massive advantage of being able to be
used as a tablet
because of its touchscreen display which
enables apple pencil support
which is the biggest advantage it has
the macbook air obviously doesn't have a
touchscreen display
and you can't really use it while
walking around the house like you can
with the ipad you have to use it either
on a
tabletop or on your lap but the ipad air
4
can also be used as a laptop with the
magic keyboard case
for things like web browsing and
document typing however
i'd still say that the macbook air does
it better because you actually get a
full size
keyboard compared to a scrunch down
version with the ipad
the macbook air also gets function keys
which are incredibly useful
and the placement of the touch id sensor
on the power button
is much more convenient compared to the
ipad air 4 sensor
on top of that the macbook air's
trackpad is much
larger giving you more freedom for
swiping
and using drag and drop and it actually
performs and feels better
because it uses apple's force touch
technology
with built-in motors that simulate
clicks compared to a simple design
on the magic keyboard case however this
case does add an
extra usbc port in the hinge for
charging
leaving the ipad's main port free for
data transfers
but on the macbook air either of the two
ports can be used for transferring data
including high speed thunderbolt 3
support
which you cannot get on the ipad now by
far
the most annoying thing about using the
ipad air as a laptop replacement
with that magic keyboard case is that if
you're in a zoom call
the webcam ends up on the side of the
ipad
so it looks really weird when you look
at the display like you normally would
yes it does use a higher quality camera
compared to the 720p
webcam on the macbook air but they're
surprisingly
not that big of a difference just check
it out for yourself
this is a microphone and webcam quality
test on
the 2020 ipad air 4. and this
is a microphone and webcam quality test
on the 2020
m1 macbook air so yeah it's definitely a
bit annoying that the webcam is on the
side
but the worst part is that when you're
in a zoom call your webcam
shuts off when you start multitasking
and that's what i want to get into next
the macbook air just does a much better
job for multitasking
you can move your apps around the screen
very easily
in any position you'd like on the ipad
air
it just doesn't feel the same because
you can only have two apps open at once
and that's because of the software
differences
ipad os is extremely limited compared to
the more traditional mac os software
which allows you to easily run multiple
apps at the same time
and if you really need to you can get up
to 16 gigs of ram
compared to only 4 gigs on the ipad air
which is a huge difference
and making it worse the ipad air only
comes with 64 gigs of storage
and if you want to match the base 256
gigs on the macbook air
you have to spend another 150 bucks to
upgrade it
but that's it no further ssd options
beyond that
which is extremely limiting compared to
the macbook air
which supports up to two terabytes of
storage
but getting back to software support the
m1 macbook air supports
so much more apps including x86 apps
which run extremely well using rosetta
so if you're ever in need of
professional full-sized apps
the macbook air is so much better for
example
you can get the full versions of apps
like final cut
lightroom classic xcode logic
premiere pro and much more that you
simply cannot get on the ipad
now in the past ipads have always had a
huge advantage
by having access to the massive ios app
library but now everything has changed
with the m1 max the new m1 macbook air
can essentially download and use
every single app that's available on the
ipad if you take advantage of
side loading for example i was able to
play call of duty mobile
with controller support right on the
macbook air
in full screen mode with excellent
performance
taking it even further i was able to
play four ipad games at the same time
while being able to control them and
view them
all at once which you can't do on the
ipad
and as for performance all four apps ran
perfectly without stressing the m1 chip
at all the only issue i had was with
touch based games which require
a touchscreen to work properly for games
like that the ipad
is definitely the right choice
especially since you can use it like a
tablet while playing on the couch
or walking around which is the only real
gaming advantage
for the ipad air now on the other hand
the m1 macbook air can also play
mac games using rosetta like league of
legends and
cs go it can also play windows games
using either crossover or parallel 16
and it can easily run emulators like
dolphin
for nintendo games with no issues at all
and because of the massive difference in
performance
as you can see in these geekbench
results for both the cpu and the
graphics
the m1 macbook air is not only
a much much better choice for gaming but
it's also a better choice for
professionals
doing things like video or photo editing
and to take it even further
the m1 macbook air is rated for 15 hours
of web browsing battery life
compared to just 10 on the ipad air 4.
the ipad does get the advantage of
tablet use
for media consumption like watching
youtube videos
but the macbook air still has two major
advantages in this area
the larger 13.3 inch display that uses a
16 by 10 aspect ratio
making widescreen videos fill up more of
the screen and
the speakers sound much better as well
just hear it for yourself
[Music]
so based on all of that you can tell
that i'm extremely excited
about the m1 macbook air and i think
it's totally worth the extra cash
over the ipad air 4 for everyone
except for those who prefer to have a
touch based tablet experience
with apple pencil support so here's the
final rundown to finish off this review
the ipad air 4 is great but the m1
macbook air
is much much better if you disagree with
me go ahead and comment your thoughts
down below and be sure to check out our
m1 macbook pro review
right over there thank you guys for
watching and we'll see you in
the next one